a major system is zipping across the
region outside temp right now eight
degrees but it feels like 20 below Jamie
well stay up the roads if you can folks
lots of reports of black ice oh you got
to watch out for that dangerous black
ice it's transparent and sneaky hard to
see black ice that's right Marcy keep
your loved ones safe and warn them to
stay off the streets tonight because of
menacing life-robbing black black ice
Isaac
y'all for real though
this right here yeah this goes out to
all our fallen homeless yo
come on hey yo real tough all right
seems like a waste right
does that make me a dick
okay I'm a dick okay I'm a dick I'm
sorry okay
for our homes
come on man okay bye
okay
okay you need to respect homie okay
for the homies
whoa
trash beer what come on hey beer is beer
geez I cannot win on this what fine I'm
out on board with this but I'll do it
hey man what you doing
oh man
it's more of a symbol than a gesture
somebody back me up on this hey hey man
that's disrespectful right there you
just do it fine fine I'm poured out I
waste the damn beer then
you know I'm just not a waster you know
I save everything Jamal knows if you eat
a piece of pizza and don't eat the crust
I eat the crust if we do a drive-by
shooting I will go back for the shell
cases not to hide the evidence but
because you can recycle those they have
value man just like this beer I can't
waste nothing y'all it's physically
impossible for me to waste this
I can't do it
Jamal can you pour it off for me
dude I mean it's not gonna bring it back
so it's not gonna bring him back
and I'm trying to help people out over
here okay you know what jQuery I don't
know what you need to think about
yourself sometimes before you start
insinuating yourself in other people's
business well you know what be nice I'm
gonna insinuate my stuff whenever and
wherever I please because it's a free
country [__]
and that's all you're doing call me a
[__] again
I would like to see what happens I would
love to see what happens oh you do oh
absolutely so why don't you come and
bring it then [__]
see no you are writing my last nerve and
I ain't even playing no more I am not
even playing no more oh it's all then
let's do something okay you want to go
do something [__]
there we go let's do something
let's do something [__] what
we told you not to mess with us [__]
y'all just saw that [__] turning into
two little girls right well
all right friends the first fight of the
evening will feature one of my slaves
versus one of the slaves of my
distinguished guest Mr Jacob Dixon
you know Robert I hope you are as
gracious a loser as you are a host
all right enough talk
Devils fight to the death
wow
hey hey
um question
how do we get out of this thing a lot um
it's it's really simple just let me
pretend to kill you
maybe it just makes more sense if I
yeah yeah I just
I want to make it believable so that's
what I was going for too what the blazes
is going on over there in that endless
clench look at him
apocalypse
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just die from this from this
um uh just you know what just something
doesn't feel right so if I can just if I
just let me go with me
[Music]
that was it that was it this feels much
more real so what why
um sir what do you mean why all right my
God
oh
I'm getting frustrated now damn it kill
yeah I don't know it's not a thing
another thing I think okay I'm gonna get
him I got him let me get you though just
let me get you though no let me get you
no let me get you where's my ideas
let me get you though just like can you
just let me get you for a second please
stop fighting like sissies and kill each
other
all right
we'll back up
uh you run at me real fast just do a
bunch of spins and kicks and flourishes
and I'll just knock you out one punch
and then you're dead no wait wait what
what I'm sorry so you can look cool no
thank you if someone doesn't die soon I
will kill you both thank you
that's my boy
[Music]
no I'm not getting stronger for my
punches
let's be fair okay we both slam into
each other and we both die Fair
this will be good two three
oh you son of a [__] you were never
gonna fall you won't even try to fall
down you were never the biggest thing
you can help my balls hey everybody
War's over
slavery is abolished
sorry
we'll call it a draw don't
good for you though huh
thank you let's go well wait before you
no no no no no no just just if it just
if we met if I may who do you think
would have won the fight yeah between
the two of us you will be in room 237
and you have free Wi-Fi there also from
6 a.m to 10 a.m every morning there's a
free continental breakfast
oh
continental breakfast yes from 6 a.m to
10 A.M
so what's continental then
very good
Garcon
a one admission for the continental
breakfast you can just help yourself sir
interesting European style
[Music]
When in Rome
a forbidden fruit
well aren't you a tiny plum
[Music]
well la di da
vapor and everything
and who are you my little friend
not a spoon not a fork but something in
between a papoon
but will you think of next Germany
[Music]
European countries lay before me
where should I fly to First
the pit of the donut
thank you turkey
buckled up let's see where we shall go
next ah the Danish
clearly from Brussels
um
hello Greece where the yogurt flows like
water
yes
like go good but to stay
um
so good pulling into Spain
[Music]
um baked to Perfection can you believe
this it all comes with the room
[Music]
oh
I love being incontinent I love being
uncomfortable and they like to the
senses this is my friend isn't it yeah
[Music]
what I'm having
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's so good
oh good afternoon sir how can I help you
well Davis I will be staying
indefinitely
but sir don't you know that you've
always been here
[Music]
really
continental breakfast
right around the corner
[Music]
the right triangle's longest side is
called the hypotenuse
and it's this side here see the long
ER I wish I were high on Pop news three
sides I wish I was high on pot news
[Applause]
okay okay Mr Morris it's very funny it's
very funny but let's get back to the
lesson
and if you can see the longest one where
it goes from this point that was my joke
I know man that was hilarious
no but I mean I said that labeled
anything I said it I said it I said that
please please Mr Jackson keep your
comments to yourself
thank you
now the hypotenuse it
[Applause]
that's the reason you really got me on
that one oh so great oh
principal Martel come here come here
come here uh tell principal Martel what
you said Troy oh uh
um she was talking about the hypotenuse
and I said I wish I was high on pot news
I'm sorry
he likes it
principal martel's pool
that's a very funny just one more towel
principal Martel I said that Mr Jackson
that is enough what I said at first
is touring the local schools today for a
charity he's working on and tell them
what you said tell them what you said
um I wish I was high on pot news
[Applause]
Mr Iglesias Mr glacias uh I'm your
biggest fan that was my joke uh you know
it's not really cool buddy to take
credit for other people's jokes
Hey listen funny stuff I'm doing this
big tour right now you want to see about
maybe we could talk about you opening I
need an opener oh
um sure what do you think is that okay
of course what
he deserved it all right so across from
the longest side is a 90 degree angle
good thing I've got a 90 degree dangle
you will never be Troy why are you
trying to be like Troy
dick
a two nerdy girl
so the hypotenuse
[Applause]
oh my God oh
good evening Saint Paul it's your city
news at five I'm Jamie throneberg and
I'm Marcy whitchurch
weather advisories are in effect across
central Minnesota tonight with more on
that weatherman Isaac laboda Isaac
thanks Marcy a major system is zipping
across the region outside temp right now
eight degrees but it feels like 20 below
Jamie well stay off the roads if you can
folks lots of reports of black ice oh
you got to watch out for that dangerous
black ice it's transparent and sneaky
hard to see black ice that's right Marcy
keep your loved ones safe and warn them
to stay off the streets tonight because
of menacing life-robbing black black ice
I think
we have Channel 17's field reporter
Darren hempner with more Aaron
[Music]
I'm standing out here in historic Ramsey
Hill where there are currently no cars
on the street due to uh
hazardous driving conditions Darren are
you talking about black ice
that's right
oh Jesus it's frightening just to even
say black ice it's scary tricky ruthless
stuff that black ice uh perfectly safe
neighborhood can be suddenly terrorized
by the appearance of Black Ice well
one must keep in mind that just because
black ice looks different than white ice
it doesn't make it any more dangerous
also one must remember how hard it is
for Black Ice to survive what would the
authorities trying to destroy it with
the snow plows and the salt trucks but
black guys persevere Ah that's right
that's right and as you can see right
now the city is being controlled by lots
of oppressive white snow making it hard
for all people to advance and we don't
hear much news about that now do we no
we do not well thank you very much
brother Darren but let's be honest black
ice is the real Menace last night I was
in a perfectly safe neighborhood walking
away from an ATM machine when black ice
just snuck up on me and practically
robbed me of my balance ouch that sounds
exactly like something black ice would
do well I just hope that folks watch out
so the white snow doesn't blind them and
keep them from seeing what's
going on all I'm saying is I can't think
of a single Christmas song about black
ice lots of cheerful uplifting songs
about snow so oh well for the record
black ice never asked to be out here no
it did not it's a product of the
environment
oh Hallelujah
in fact black ice didn't land on the
road the road landed on black ice
oh amen
okay next up why is America being ruined
by black people
[Music]